lehman brothers leidet unter unfassbaren
630 milliarden dollar schulden als folge
der immobilienkrise
das management hat gestern noch die
amerikanische notenbank um eine
finanzspritze
doch vergeblich heute folgte der
konkursantrag der pause verschiedener
drogen ist der schock die firmen pleite
enttäuscht redete baumarkt ist man sich
durchgerungen doch ganz klare analyse
genannt
also bitte pixi aus direkte vor der bank
kommission machte präsident eugen
automatik macht und bmw bilden
unternehmen damals nicht sofort
natürlich hat jeder sieht allerdings
[Musik]
außerdem hat er scheint ganz sauber
standort früh am morgen dann nochmals
und ist das alles schon amerika ist
verheerend wäre die grösste bank zum
schwächste glied in der kette und
schlafstadt der ganze volkswirtschaft zu
spielen wenn hierher denn man sehen über
die entwicklung im höchsten maße läuft
ja also abgrund hat sich ein
nachwuchsstar am 15
september montag konkurs von lehman
brothers eröffnet wollte ich war nach
einer beschleunigung und beschäftigt
eine krise brachte das ist die gerade
die situation verschlechterte sich sehr
sehr schnell
es gab das risiko dass die ubs in den
nächsten wochen zahlungsunfähig werden
könnte in diesem moment begannen wir zu
handeln
in england und deutschland herr erste
gespräche stattgefunden und auch mir sie
jetzt zweimal musik findet druck ist
riesig wenn jetzt nägel mit köpfen
machen
wenn wir das schlimmste vorbereitet
mehr könnte voraus dass der tiefpunkt
erreicht ist situation wird sich die
nächsten tag stabil ist ja das wissen
darüber andere banken dass sie in
starker zufluss von hube ist geld hängt
befürchte die sehkraft nicht riskiere
peter huber ist muss der sache helfen
macht das natürliche hockenheim ich das
nicht wir sind immer noch mit private
investoren nimmt später entweder einen
dritten letzten großen investor wo
kapital bringt oder milizen mit der
nationalbank für vier massiven plastik
vor ihrer bilanz und leidet einmal
verschlechtert stimmt dann bequem
hauptgrund platz für trübe ist weil wir
alle katastrophe peter frage ist nicht
ob mir helfen
tragisch in welchem umfang es geht doch
sich nur andere möglichkeit
es geht nur flüssig prächtig zur
nationalbank und das hat am 20 september
hätten wir das der ubs lady geöffneter
geschafft zahlen - und da angriff
vermissen die maßnahme vorbereitung team
ist voll und das machen was sitzt und
sich das nachher geleitet wird sicher
dass wieder durch 52 wasser sie
weiterstadt mit der bh sie was soll ich
da machen aber das ist ja dass sie
langsam analogen verschafft uns allen ja
also philipp er könnte doch eventuell es
geht auch kreis eventuell mehr meint
jetzt ihr lang und ich könnte jetzt am
jean pierre und sage ihm er segelt mit
dem stabilisierungsplan nie verstanden
wie in der 70 was ist danach richten was
macht der bundesrat merz litern kommt
der flug verlief problemlos nach angaben
der rettungsflugwacht konnte bundesrat
merz dem team des berner inselspitals in
stabilem zustand übergeben werden
während 1 media die 70 alte herr mit der
2 vertrag der europäischen nachricht die
nach rom
dass der bundesrat merz herzinfarkt auf
der intensivstation wie der insel ist
und natürlich selber sorgt jetzt
ausgerechnet in einem moment wo man die
rettungsaktion der stadt
vp-finanzminister russ also ja das ist
um erwartete zusätzliche verschärfung
vorderachse ohne finanzminister merz
verkündet bundespräsident fußball das
ubs rettungspaket material
seit wochen verfolgt der bundesrat mit
großer aufmerksamkeit wie sich die
finanzmärkte verändern
die masche aufgrund von verschiedenen
lage analysen die wir gemacht haben
zusammen mit rebecca zusammen mit hessen
haben wir gestern geschlossen
das maßnahmenpaket gutzuheißen mit
diesen 60 milliarden dollar wird die
zweckgesellschaft die illiquiden
position der ubs übernommen
am ende dieser transaktion ist ego es
völlig befreit von diesen 60 milliarden
schwierigen positionen die in
zweckgesellschaften liegen
wir haben zeit snb die ubs hat keine
zeit
dieses permanente druck jedes quartal
kommt natürlich kommentare würde
resultat man muss diese aktiven wir
werden bei uns sie wissen wir sind da
für die ewigkeit
wir haben zeit das macht eine grosse
differenz wir können diese position
halten wir können ruhigen handel
[Musik]
krisenjahr 2008 der zusammenbruch des
amerikanischen häusermarkt die
hypotheken zu sogenannten subprime
papieren geschmiert werden plötzlich
wertlos banken wir die ubs verlieren
milliarden und weil die nachfrage nach
konsumgütern ausbleibt werden fabriken
geschlossen wie dieses duell modus werk
tausende stehen auf der straße
gleichzeitig kurbelt der amerikanische
staat die wirtschaft an
dafür braucht er geld viel geld das
anderswo gesucht werden muss der
druckluft bank eine sich immer darf sie
aber du darfst das finanzkrise nicht
heute noch stecke staaten natürlich
studie braucht sparmassnahme studie
häufiger subvention nach hayes
glaubwürdigkeit gelände um das in rücken
dazu als motor heiß müsse dafür sorgen
dass die im besitz geld unversteuert
kassiert
im visier die grossbank ubs soeben
gerettet dank schweizer staatshilfe für
die usa die ideale bank ein testfall im
kampf um steuern
ich glaube der amerikanische strom gang
als abschreckendes beispiel stadt trier
und da ist natürlich weit bekannt die
große bank die über das schweizerisch
serie comics siebzehnter oktober 2008
new york einen tag nach der schweizer
ubs retten
eine sitzung in der amerikanischen
notenbank
die öffentlichkeit weiß nichts davon
die ubs präsentiert den amerikanischen
justizbehörden ihre untersuchung über
die steuervergehen die sie in
monatelanger arbeit erstellte
foto firma ist urs zulauf der chefjurist
foto gemacht und einige das dossier nach
sehr früh die risikoanalyse es sie dass
der amerikaner es mal nicht ob sie das
ubs lake nykvist vor deiner manöver vor
der bank und dass sie darauf dringen
dass rasch eine musikleistung und das
die amtshilfe tweets gewöhnt ist sie im
üblichen trapp dass das viel zu lang
gerät und das zu unsicher ist ob das
überhaupt klappt also ist die message
ist denkt sie mehr wunden punkt
amerikaner hätte die ubs um solche
kotiert ist das völlig ersetzen müssen
reagieren sie hat andreas topp vortag
zerstört zuversicht genommen gibt es
erst der verübt 201 khedira zieht du
wärst von daher ist das für eine
beschwerde du bist jetzt
bundesverwaltungsgericht das wurde und
bestätigt seine stimme natürlich alles
sehr gut sie dass die säcke meine liebe
das ist das normale verfahren das weißt
du doch dieses recht wäre es
amerikanischer sicht erst recht verletzt
darum geht es das verfahren nach
us-recht müssen sie die daten liefern
dieses jahr klappt und das überleben
schon gar nicht die finanzkrise mache
aus um die verfahren zu beschleunigen
jetzt hätte was ich über 200 was
wahrscheinlich
der personalbestand wird aufgestockt
stadtverwaltung ausgemacht die hätte ich
heute nichts für juristen gehen möchten
wir sie mit den eigenen verfahren sind
es aber nur sie deckt mit heute das
nicht erst ein jahr später hätten auch
der bundesrat entscheiden
das bundesamt für justiz ludmilla
liefere
denn einfach prioritäten gesetzt wollte
sie aber gewaltig hat sich bei mir aber
sicher dass sie einfach lange wege im
bund meinen geschwistern nachhinein
betrachtet hat die verwaltung dies zu
beginn wahrscheinlich unterschätzt so
schnell auf die amerikanische wirtschaft
aber was ist es was wichtig lage ohne zu
sich verwundert dass die amerikaner
nicht bereit allerdings verbleibt und
das hat verheerende auswirkungen für die
volkswirtschaft dies offiziell tut es
einfach weh was das für dieses land
bietet das schiff geht ja schon mit
ihnen liefere die stoßen wir an grenzen
vom bankgeheimnis was echte der liebe
eher kaputten bank aber die ganze
schweiz ist aber nun einmal vor 250
amerikanische steuerbetrüger ums leben
für ihn ist klar der herr aus
vertraglicher was man alles machen
das führt zu kevin conners sie so gerade
die ist so lange warten und nicht über
co die lösungen
wochen vergehen aber sechster dezember
2008 notiert los zulauf die
bundesverwaltung hat nichts wesentliches
unternommen außer sich zu informieren
es ist hart sexy oder mit dem zuruf sehr
schöne hexe
es gibt probleme die help freiheit
zwischen departements grenze vom bund
also mehrere debatte bentlage und der
wird sofort ist es schwierig die
maschine überhaupt in das
krisen-management netz bringen dass sie
effizient unteren das ist ein problem
und nicht nur bei den größer und finma
hat das wenig anders
dass ich jedes business oder die
bankenaufsicht die hier ganz klar sie
als goldrichtige eskalation und
escalation heißt noch der dass die bank
klagt worden war und danach lag das hat
die wahrscheinliche sandy förderbank
bedeutet und der six and events ohne
bank.de den trifft als nicht nur die
banken und nicht nur die aktionäre
sondern das hat wirtschaft vor der
ganzen schweiz treffen
endlich 19 dezember 2008 akzeptiert der
bundesrat den vorschlag der
bankenaufsicht finma die lieferung der
250 namen außerhalb des regulären
verfahrens vorzubereiten bankgeheimnis
hin oder her
doch ein bundesrat hat bedenken seine
abteilung versucht wo es zu lauf das
dossier zu entziehen
ich glaube dass remedy hintertreffen
natürlich wird hier vorgestellt aber es
ist egal
damals hatte sogar schon sagt er und
macht darüber dass das jetzt nicht
dieses bier weil die es besser machen
aber dass da hatte sie den ball nach
kroos traf
[Musik]
es ist dass der patient von bundesrat
hans rudolf merz dass widerstand leistet
märz erklärt im kleinen kreis er könne
die politische verantwortung nicht
übernehmen
sein chef ban da alexander karrer
versucht noch einmal die datenlieferung
zu stoppen
er schickt bundesrat merz eine notiz der
schmerzvolle abschied vom bankgeheimnis
[Musik]
der macher der neuen absatz
herr bundesrat merz ich bin nach wie vor
der meinung dass die weitergabe von
kundennamen außerhalb des
amtshilfeverfahrens die wohl
schlechteste aller varianten ist dieses
vorgehen würde den bundesrat in eine
äußerst schwierige lage versetzen
medias ist bundesrats und der rote kempe
vom bankgeheimnis machen des klinikums
soviel ich weiß hat er sich sehr für die
verteidigung des bankgeheimnisses
eingesetzt das ist sicher ehrenvoll ob
es realistisch war ist eine andere frage
die ereignisse haben gezeigt dass eine
gewisse flexibilität wünschbar gewesen
wäre
man kann aber einem funktionär nicht
vorwerfen dass er für seine überzeugung
einsteht
ich schlage daher vor dass wir im moment
ich schlage vor dass der bundesrat
wieder selbst das heft in die hand nimmt
das vorgesehene treffen von bundesrätin
eveline widmer schlumpf mit dem
amerikanischen justizminister am 23
februar wird die dazu eine erste
gelegenheit mit besten grüßen etc
ja das ist es frau sie bitte ob die
pioniere bundesrat merz messi
[Applaus]
man hat festgestellt dass die usa nicht
nachgeben würden und die diskussionen
innerhalb der verwaltung für die schweiz
keine günstige lösung brachten
man musste deshalb handeln die banken
die schweizer wirtschaft und die
schweizer politik kamen zum schluss man
müsse eine einigung mit den usa
erreichen
jetzt ist auch bundesrat merz
einverstanden
die usa erhalten rund 250 ubs kunden
haben außerhalb des regulären
amtshilfeverfahrens usb-sticks und man
hätte meine ich denke das war eine
gravierende verletzung des
bankgeheimnisses der stärkere bestimmte
die regeln amerika hat den schweizer
presse und schwitzt es realistisch sie
und ergebnisse tropft sie hätten durch
bedeutet das mehr
das macht das mehr schweizer bbc zur
rettig voller sie stehen der verwalter
grossbank unnötige fouls über den
helikopter und über die normale
gesetzgebungen und berge hinweg springen
also das bankgeheimnis hatten am 21
miami der morgen nach der datenübergabe
die ars die amerikanische steuerbehörde
reicht jetzt beim dortigen gericht
zivilklage gegen die ubs ein
es ist die sogenannte john doe summons
klage darin fordert die au es weitere
52.000 namen namen von ubs kunden die
steuerhinterziehung begangen haben soll
solche forderungen hat die schweiz
bisher umgehend zurückgewiesen
das dritte geld oder dass das dass dir
der druck weiter geht das das hätte man
mit einem österreicher aber schon durch
brutalität und am nächsten tag kann man
sich auch mit der massive zusätzliche
forderung seit mehr als schockiert
persönlich was er denkt das ist ja das
ist eine absolute geschmacklosigkeit
wenn jetzt schweiz sonnig wir besser
machen
recht so den enten und ews etwas und
begegne die tussi und am gleichen tag
das enforcement das sogenannte in form
von john doe summons vor dem gericht
etwa gelächter das etwa also wirklich
das hat mir enttäuscht vor arbeitszeit
konferenz hartes jahr
die herren beauty rowdys und natürlich
der gerade
wird am morgen in die haare
den hätte ich wohl nichts zusammen
papier zivilklage erwartet treffen sich
vom verfahren quasi aus antwortet sie
ich liebe dich von deinen 256
kundendaten samantha mc twist dass die
amerikanische steuerbehörde
er sei jetzt zugriff auf die usa und der
schweizer bankgeheimnis eine alte
leidensgeschichte nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg entbrennt der streit erstmals
usa haben guthaben von schweizer banken
die milliarden höhe eingefroren
sie fordern kunden nahmen die schweiz
geschickt minister stucki nach moshi bin
ich doch loki mit seinen mitarbeitern
vor seiner abreise nach amerika mit
recht sagt der herr stucki kurz vor dem
start zu den journalisten
hier herrscht nebel hoffen wir dass
drüben die sonne scheinen
weil die schweiz nazi deutschland half
raub gold zu waschen gestalten sich die
verhandlungen schwierig ihn in amerika
mächtig amerika unglaublich gut
verhandelt für tweets schweizer müsse
zahlen aber sich sehr abträglich sind
sich noch erledigen sie uns banken das
parlament für das bankgeheimnis im jahre
1935 ein also kurz vor ausbruch des
zweiten weltkriegs in dieser zeit
versuchten viele verängstigte anleger
ihr kapital in der schweiz zu verstecken
hier ist es ab sofort geschützt denn die
parlamentarier haben beschlossen der
bank informationen weitergibt wird mit
gefängnis bestraft
das wollen wir ja bewegte zeiten europa
und leute angst vor bolschewismus von
nationalismus und da wurde der erfolg
des bankgeheimnisses gegründet es löse
sie spitzelaktivitäten vorsieht nazi
deutschland und frankreich und es ist
rundgang der bankkunden schützen und
technik man kann darüber diskutieren wie
es entstanden ist
aber ich denke es ist er mit guten
absichten entstanden um anleger zu
schützen die in ländern lebten in denen
ihr vermögen bedroht war bedroht aus
politischen oder anderen gründen die die
schweiz nicht gutheißen konnte nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg
der wirtschaftsaufschwung die blütezeit
des bankgeheimnis beginnt ausländer die
damals ihr geld in die schweiz bringen
wissen keiner erfährt davon
und weil runter um hohe inflation
herrscht ist die schweiz zusätzlich
attraktiv es geht nur mit die hand
großvater das ganze vermögen die
inflation verloren wenn das bewusste
wissen 27 diktatur gegen europa spanien
griechenland portugal und das ist eine
ganz andere aufgabe gerade zum schutz
vor dem start und pflegeteams sie blüht
vor der diktatur geschützt hat ich war
die legitim sei und mit der eu und mit
demokratie jährige für europa hat und
irene richtig entwickelt wurde also ein
viel weniger legitimität das frühere
nötig start zum teil exorbitant die
stühle gebe desto mehr ist das thema
wurde also machen wir gut erinnere ein
ganz normaler grenzsteuersatz von 0 91
prozent bei einer 100 pfund verdient
hätten uns die punkte abliefern
das hat natürlich dazu erklärt das lied
versucht ein muster was das genau
bedeutet ist das bankgeheimnis mehr
benutzt wurde um
steuerhinterzieher durch
steuerhinterziehung eine möglichkeit zu
geben hier kapital in der schweiz
anzulegen das bankgeheimnis herzig
private banking hunde privatunterricht
arbeitskollegen aus russland und stück
hinter sich quasi akzeptiert
geschäftsmodell sich dass man unternimmt
die studie sollte es ermöglicht dass man
hat stühle hinterzogenen staaten
insbesondere in acht flotte und dass das
natürlich ein bisschen wo befindet die
staaten überhaupt nicht geschätzt ich
irgendwie nachvollziehbar ob das
bestätigte nicht dahin von der das ist
es auch was zu überprüfen es sind die
goldenen zeiten für schweizer banken
[Musik]
doch immer wieder flackert kritik auf
zum beispiel in den 80er jahren die
sozialdemokratische banken initiative
[Musik]
denn etwas bug eines welle abschaffen
mit alten bekannten gründen region um
das thema nochmal für studenten und
unser kriminell legal der gelder von
potentaten und so weiter und daran
gehindert ist gewählt diese banken
initiative die schränkt die
konkurrenzfähigkeit ein sie schadet den
bankplatz reizt sie schadet dem
vertrauen in die banken und damit
schadet sie doch eindeutig auch unserem
arbeitsplatzangebote diesen bereichen
sie mögen uns ja volkswirtschaftlich
wenig wenig vernunft zutrauen aber so
viele haben mir schon in der
primarschule gelernt nämlich dass banken
eine wichtige funktion haben
aber sie haben nicht einen staat im
staat zu sein und sie haben nicht das
recht sie haben nicht das recht eigene
eigene gesetze quasi privat ihn zu
erlassen von daher woche wie immer man
diese banken initiative beurteilt aber
ihre ihre art das einfach aus landes
schädigen darzustellen das ist
unqualifizierter und weisen wir ihn alle
voll zurück es ist gut hier für die
diskussion sie will er es sei nun die
große steuerhinterzieher der dämon abaca
am kliniken und irak feld die real stars
industriellen charakter ist die
natürliche
[Musik]
die initiative wird abgelehnt
nur 27 prozent stimmen zu erinnern sie
zwar schieden nach unten und der spitze
war vielleicht hinterher das müsse mit
sido unbedingt habe als das
bankgeheimnis fällt in steuersachen und
zum anderen erhält man natürlich heute
meckern argumentiere der ge arbeitsplatz
verloren als vermögen ab
der vorteil ist sicher mehrere faktoren
kaffee und damit ist das bankgeheimnis
oder das steuerhinterziehungs bank eines
quasi direkt demokratisch legitimiert
worden
das bankgeheimnis eine institution für
den missbrauch sei die schweiz nicht
verantwortlich heißt es noch im märz
2008 das schweizer bankgeheimnis ist
nicht die ursache der
steuerhinterziehung in anderen staaten
dafür sind meist volkswirtschaftliche
fiskalische oder private gründe
verantwortlich
da hat die herrschende mehrheitsmeinung
wieder und hätte und sprachen können
kann für die strato den angreifern
auf das schweizerische bankgeheimnis
kann ich allerdings voraussagen
an diesem bankgeheimnis werdet ihr euch
die zähne ausbeißen es steht nämlich
nicht zur disposition
[Musik]
wissen sie in der politik macht man dann
bei äußerungen die übrigens sehr
ernsthaft ich bin überzeugt seine
deklaration war ernst gemeint
[Musik]
alle informationen zeigten dass es immer
schwieriger wurde und man entweder zeit
gewinnen musste oder den druck zu
handeln wurde immer stärker
dieses jahres klar dass so viele
änderungen auf das bankgeheimnis zu
kommen und armin technologischen
entwicklung dass es eine frage der zeit
ist wie lange es bestehen kann und auch
vom druck der von außen kam speziell in
halb europa weil die eigenen länder
scheinbar nicht in der lage waren
weder deutschland noch frankreich ihre
leute zu überzeugen da sie gern steuern
hinterziehen
die welt bewegt sich und ein jahr später
mussten wir uns anpassen für sie die
bohlen tatsächlich fast auf den tag
genau ein jahr später
der abschied vom traditionellen
bankgeheimnis die wortwahl ist jetzt
nicht mehr mag ich sondern
technokratisch meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren der bundesrat hat heute
beschlossen dass die schweiz den
oecd-standard bei der amtshilfe in
steuersachen gemäss artikel 26 des
oecd-musterabkommens übernehmen will
sie war gerade wenn sie die szene
anschauen dann sehen sie dass merz einen
anderen gesichtsausdruck hat als damals
als er im nationalrat erklärte die
anderen würden sich am bankgeheimnis die
zähne ausbeißen seien ausdruck an der
pressekonferenz ist ein ganz anderer
es war eine große enttäuschung für ihn
aber er ist realist das ändert sich
jetzt im verhältnis zum ausland betrug
und hinterziehung nicht mehr
unterscheiden
natürlich ist das eine schwächung des
absoluten bankgeheimnisses
der wandel ist sehr rasch das hätte
elfmeter finanzkrise um echte
staatskrise zu das hätte dort bist du
jetzt dass man wahrscheinlich hier
ideologische befangenheit vielleicht
zwei die wahrheit muss oben fällt kein
treter setzt sich nicht vor jedem tag
auf der agenda
aber jetzt finanziell war habe man auch
gern mit einem auto modelle hat die
welle festhalte nimmt mir haupt die
negative sich nach weniger war
alt bundesrat merz will sich heute nicht
mehr öffentlich dazu äußern betonte aber
er habe stets im landesinteresse
gehandelt
fakt ist ab märz 2009 gilt das
bankgeheimnis für steuerhinterzieher
nicht mehr
[Musik]
doch die usa wollen noch mehr
sie verlangen rückwirkend 52.000 namen
von angeblichen steuerhinterziehung mit
der john doe summons klage eingereicht
nur einen tag nachdem die schweiz 250
ubs name lieferte und die us behörden
wollen die daten praktisch per sofort
jetzt verlangt daher ist die 250
kundendaten und das ist erschreckend wie
weit ist die us-rechte der ubs nummer 10
zieht man für einen antwort
wahrscheinlich verlustseite da ja es
macht mir mit dass sie mit natürlich
wird das steht ubs wieder vorm abgrund
da bin ich ein wenig vor dem us richter
schweizer recht zu fassen absolute
chance aber mehr filme machen
eidgenossenschaft muss als partei ist
das verfahren bringe das ist möglich den
usa der herzen der bundesrat merz
geschrieben und hätte es per e-mail
gemacht aber nette briefe geschrieben
hätte quasi per e mail verschickt und
händler aber viele andere die empfänger
in der bundesverwaltung chefbeamte
parlament geschickt quasi um den jetzt
zeigen um was es geht und über die
straße wo speziell nach wie vor aus holz
ist komitee nach einem rückpass von
bundesrat merz das meer hat die
russische präsident kann quasi mit dem
mittels da hat irgendein mitarbeiter um
14 04 10 11 mail user klar armee das
gerät mit mehr verfehlt man auf die
höchste stufe musste präsident
unterschrieben
aber was weiß ich nicht stört es sie
dass man andere debatte meint abc am
dienstag unter druck fühlt im
finanzdepartement
zulaufs reaktion auf miami sei
übertrieben gewesen rechtfertigt sich
merz noch heute und die schweiz habe ja
gehandelt sagte die schweiz
intervenierte indem sie einen amicus
curiae brief ans gericht in florida
sandte das bedeutete für uns dass das
juristische verfahren welches von der
schweiz verlangte 52.000 namen zu
liefern
nicht nur die ubs betraf sondern auch
unsere rechtsordnung und unsere
souveränität
wir sahen unsere rolle darin unsere
rechtsordnung zu schützen und deshalb
haben wir uns entschlossen einzugreifen
sommer 2009 das gerichtsverfahren
beginnt die ubs anwälte sind in florida
und auch die eidgenossenschaft hat ihre
vertreter geschickt
einer davon ist rudolph wies
mehr sie im training neben den
amerikanischen kanzlei humanismus
vordermann amerikanische rechte wie man
muss antworten wie wenn man so oft
treten was erreicht was verpflichten als
man hat und mithin also eine erschloss
szenario gemacht und komisch das fertig
seid satz trikots bier trinkt und da
läutet das telefon und die damalige chef
der achtmal traf sie und ex cdu
mehrheitlich erreicht oder erlösung
jetzt komme skizzieren und das hat der
verein bedeutet gottlob müsse man nicht
fotos amerikanische gericht
unsere regierung und die schweizer
regierung haben eine einigung erzielt
bezüglich des ubs rechtsstreits in
florida
region der ubs-staatsvertrag darin geben
sich die usa mit 4450 stadt 52.000
kundennamen zufrieden
anstatt die 250 was die verlangt hat
immer so sagen wow 04 4450 4500 vor der
erste konter stand hat müssen die werte
die aliquote darüber verhandelt der
staatssekretär an bio direktor leibold
und andere reichlich gefunden die sehr
guten job gemacht woran der leipold sehr
gute rolle gespielt dass alte chef vom
bundesamt für justiz ich seit ich
vertrete das recht und das ändert
amerikaner aktiviert
[Musik]
der konflikt scheint ein für alle mal
gelöst
der vertrag zwischen der schweiz und den
usa steckt nämlich auch viele andere
banden ab die amerikanische siebte
dominique sie sie möchte sich vor
behaupten könne
im eine späte zeitpunkt andere gleich
klagen tv stürzte und die cdu für eine
sonne klaric drängt wo haben erlaubt
dass merkel ii startet die klage die
frau könnte gleich behandeln das problem
und nach heraus dass vor dem unfall das
gewicht das abkommen unter dreijährige
aus nick jürgen dargelegt worden ist
runde beschwert machen amtshilfe
realistisch dass bei uns das land nicht
bei mir sitzt parlament kann quasi
staatsvertrag durchs parlament zu
bringen um das 80 schritt offenbar nicht
gelangt juristische dienst des bundes
voraussichtlich später entschieden hat
dass das abkommen nicht innerhalb von
bestehende rechtlich sondern neues recht
schafft und ärger im parlament muss
unterbreitet weiter vom parlament
genehmigt muss werden
das hätte die situation verändert
michael ist schade aber ich sehe das
alles müssen wir die azubis und trotzdem
urteil mit dem ubs abkommen wie gehabt
weiter machen
das parlament muss jetzt das abkommen
auf die andere banken und vita michael
michael mit einem offenburg raum und hat
ein amerikaner reisig doch statt sich
warum der seinerzeit die müssen doch
haargenau wer untrainiert die konnte und
dass du wirst nicht der einzige ist
nicht so naiv früher oder später und der
die frau dazu laufen
hätten die fürther und man muss die
eigentlich müsste das allein der notruf
an die bank und das sieht man nicht
welcher wahl weil der fiktion frächter
hauptmärkte sich eine absolute ausnahme
ev und soziales noch wie gehabt um den
takt und im raum musik betroffen sich
also als mdv wenn wir es ja doch nur gut
dass man hier klare jedem abkommen auf
die andere banken die sache nach einem
tag ruhe
michael das ist realität aussagen
restaurants angesteckt
die erklärung ab wandert dann würde das
problem bereinigt oder die zkb oder der
basler kb
es ist ja klar wir die bereinigung
stattfinden weil er klar was der
priester in der ist und man wieder
rentieren zurück und kommen gerade wenn
sie anwendbar
rein hypothetisch das hat die also
bedeutet klaric würdet umsätze dass du
dir fall von der bank pcs muster wird
ubs das heißt der hat er die villa müsse
parlament gar und die hatte nach der
vorstellung aber immer neues recht
geschaffen und das ist es wo der
bundesrat muss mir dass ich zeit zu
recht nie hätte ich mich zeitweise
problem war mir hey oder banken mit den
usa auf der basis von bestehen der
rechte der schweiz selber verbockt so
zeigen wir der ausdruck bringen und dass
politik
diesmal haben die amerikanischen
steuerfahnder auch kleinere
geldinstitute und sogar kantonalbanken
im visier wie die recherchen von einer
großen reiter und an gemälde zeigen das
us-justizministerium droht gleich zehn
schweizer war die credit suisse soldaten
über amerikanische steuersünder liefern
aber auch die privatbank julius bär
die kleine st und offenbar auch zwei
banken mit staatsgarantie die zürcher
kantonalbank und die basler kantonalbank
selbst der geschäftsführer der
schweizerisch-amerikanischen
handelskammer staunen new york im märz
die manager der kleinen st galler
privatbank wegelin auf dem weg zum
gericht
[Musik]
die usa haben die bank angeklagt sie
musste ihre schalter schließen und 74
millionen dollar buße bezahlen
die usa haben den druck massiv erhöht
logische folge das ist es nicht dass ubs
spezifisch exklusives problem ist
sondern das so und das natürlich bezirks
ist das garmin kam die us-steuerbehörde
durch die offenlegung der gemacht sehr
viele informationen habe überzeugt er
hat jetzt die banken jetzt andere
berater der hetze welt also sehr viel
mehr information erkannt hätte mittwoch
in der vita auf die nächste bank ins
visier
logische folge und das ist nicht so wie
man die 2
ich stecke mit den amerikanern wo man ab
2011 verhandlungen geführt dabei für
andere banken die bank abc.de dafür die
verhandlungen geführt und twittert
innerhalb von versteht und konditionen
von dem zweiten paket kann wenn dieser
aber miserabel
[Musik]
wir können ihnen heute das resultat
präsentieren einer dreijährigen
diskussion und auch eine dreijährigen
intensiven auseinandersetzung unter der
verhandlungs leitung von staatssekretär
michael ambühl mit vielen vielen auf und
ab während diese drei jahre
der so genannte us steuerdeal wenn eine
bank amerikanische steuerrecht verletzt
hat kann sie nun ihre altlast bereinigen
sie muss dazu den usa melden wie viele
us konnten sie seit august 2008
verwaltete die bank muss eine busse
bezahlen aber sie entgeht einer anklage
kam relativ saftige busse kurze satz
fällt sie hätte aber auch die jetzige
frau sie nicht direkt vergleichbar mit
dem fall ubs will die bank nach der ubs
nachdem ubs vorfall noch amerikanische
stück lichte genau wissend dass die
steuerhinterzieher die hannah türlich
als höheres verschulden aus du bist das
ist eine argumentation wo man bis zu
einem bestimmten grad haben
nachvollziehen wie es hat 34 prozent für
vermögen zahlt wegelin 78 je nachdem es
rechnet und jetzt reden wir von bis 40
prozent der station also die konditionen
sind um dimension ist ein echter mann
sofort mann vorstellen und um dimension
erreicht
die länder mit problemen euro 6 uhr
wartet desto natürlicher und sind mit
recht so oder so interpretiert dass
steuersünder oder auch hat hier
amerikanisches leben
der hat mal weniger müsse jetzt selber
als finanzinstitute mit wieder busse
früh schweizer gobi ist entscheidend
dass die lösung im rahmen geltenden
recht ist also mit amtshilfe regeln
münster andere als neues gesetz besser
machen sondern haye ist es recht wo mir
arbeite und das wahren der moral und
liefere amtshilfe stehe mit einer bedarf
der abschied vom bankgeheimnis
er ist nicht nur schmerzvoll sondern
auch teuer
noch ist offen für wie viele banden er
gar existenzgefährdend ist das kostet
die banken viel aber es sind die banken
die für diese schwierigkeiten
verantwortlich sind
oder hätte zelle wies der mann auch
strafbar die sache okay der
amerikanischen verstößt
insgesamt müssen wir sagen ist dieser
übergang jetzt eigentlich bis jetzt gut
gelungen weil relativ wenig geld aus der
schweiz abgeschlossen ist bis jetzt weil
großteil der kunden ihr geld zwar
deklariert hat inzwischen habe ihr geld
hier gelassen hat es gibt sogar zuflüsse
die zwar relativ gering sind nicht mehr
so groß in der vergangenheit
und wenn es so bleibt wie es jetzt ist
wird die ganze sache keinen großen
schaden für die schweiz bringen
allerdings
wir wissen nicht wie sich das weiter
entwickeln wird weil doch ein anreiz für
eine gewisse gruppe von leuten nicht
mehr vorhanden ist nämlich diejenigen
die steuern hinterziehen wollen
[Musik]